a esta hora el gobierno alemán no ha
confirmado reportes tanto en medios de
comunicación nacionales como
internacionales que aseguran que el
gobierno del canciller alemán no la sol
se habría tomado la decisión de aprobar
el envío de tanques leopard a Ucrania se
trata de un tema muy significativo pero
también muy controversial por el que el
gobierno alemán ha sido criticado
fuertemente en los últimos días se
espera que el cancillero lapsols de más
información al respecto en una sesión
que tiene prevista en el parlamento
Alemán este miércoles Es probable que el
gobierno Alemán de ese visto bueno al
envío de los tanques no solamente por
las críticas que ha recibido en los
últimos días críticas sobre su
reticencia en el plano internacional
sino también porque el nuevo ministro de
defensas Este martes tras reunirse con
el secretario general de la otan James
stoltenberg aseguró que Alemania
básicamente estaba dando vía libre para
que aliados que tuvieran tanques y que
pudieran utilizarlos empezarán ya a
entrenar soldados ucranianos en su
funcionamiento en caso de confirmar esa
aprobación el gobierno alemán no
solamente estaría dando un paso
importante para mejorar su imagen a
nivel internacional sino que también
estaría ratificando que a pesar de todas
esas dudas provenientes de los aliados
Alemania es uno de los países que más
está ayudando a Ucrania no solamente en
temas económicos sino también en temas
de envíos militares